thursday night's game went a little
extra it didn't go to overtime thanks to
the chargers but what a game it was
chris sims it looked like the chiefs
were going to win the game easily once
it went to 28 to 14 with seven minutes
and change left in the fourth quarter
but the chargers were undeterred they
score a touchdown they get the ball back
and they go down the field and they
score another and they go for two
resolute was coach anthony lynn he made
it clear that that's what he wanted to
do and that's what they did and
now and here we are i mean we talked
about the possibility and one of the
reasons i was kind of rooting for the
charges even though i ultimately picked
the chiefs i like the idea that we're
all going to wake up today and realize
the charges are pretty good and there's
gonna be a lot of people who are
surprised by the fact that the chargers
now have a fairly clear path not just to
the division title but to the number one
seed in the afc
yeah no i mean it's phenomenal i mean it
was a great game i think that's the
first thing we got to talk about right
right off the bat it had everything you
had your early early game mistakes by
philip rivers we had oh my gosh plays by
patrick mahomes where i was going that's
insane my own son committed blasphemy in
my house and said i think my homes is
better than rogers dad so that's how
that game started out i thought he was i
thought he was blasting me by by saying
i thought mahomes is better than grandpa
oh well well we already passed that we
already know that
but either way either way we saw that
early on then we saw defensive struggles
uh for a little bit and then really
offensive explosion in the fourth
quarter with a lot of good plays but we
saw philip rivers deliver once again and
he went through a little time in his
career a few years ago where he kind of
made big mistakes in the big moments and
a lot of that was because too much
pressure was on him and he didn't have
help but man did we see some magic on
those last two drives i mean some of the
throws he made to to to travis benjamin
if you're watching on tv here's the
first one of the two down the middle
that were just phenomenal timing feel
something that only a quarterback with
his experience this is the one i loved
and troy aikman talked about it where he
threw the ball like five steps before
benjamin was even out of the break uh
but just a special moment for philip
rivers and i think it showed us that
this chargers team is a different team
than years past they can deliver in
these type of moments their defense can
get stops when they need to and that's a
first for them in a long time
you know on that two point attempt and
we talked about this earlier in the week
in the context of the patrick mahomes
fourth and nine play when he rolled
right and he let it go and we couldn't
see where it was going but we knew he
had something
when when philip rivers let go of the
ball last night we couldn't see the end
zone right at home you're watching it
it's like
okay what there goes the ball
but like what's there oh my god there's
no one there except the receiver how
does a guy get that wide open chris yeah
well it's it's this is uh this is one of
the bad things about the kansas city
chiefs they have issues in the back end
every game whether it's just physical
issues with their inability to actually
cover guys man-to-man and make those
stops or there's a handful of plays
every game where i can look at and go
man they blew the coverage they messed
this up and there was a communication
issue there you could see fuller and
scandrick after the play they're looking
at each other so uh this has been a
repetitive thing with the chiefs it's
concerning it's really one of their
biggest flaws and you know one of the
big things that showed last night once
again that scares you about the chiefs
when it becomes playoff type football
like the game was last night you know
two things jumped out to me about the
game mike more than anything you know
the the chargers what did they do they
played real deep coverage and never let
the chiefs really have that big
touchdown play all night long right we
never saw that 60-yard touchdown pass or
that you know 60-yard laser that got
them down to the one-yard line those
game you know field position type
changing type plays they made the chiefs
work for it they made the chiefs throw
the ball underneath you saw all those
screens from damien williams uh early on
that were working because the chargers
were so far down the field worried about
stopping the big play
and i just couldn't think of help but
think of two things as i was watching
mike first of all they need sammy
watkins okay the chiefs need him badly
because he plays off a tyree kill oh you
want to send your coverage really deep
to stop tyree kill well then we'll throw
the ball underneath the sami watkins and
that's going to be a handful for you or
they do vice versa watkins goes deep and
now we get to see tyreke hill come
underneath and catch the short passes
which we haven't seen much lately
because there's nobody else to be scared
there because of tyree kill and then of
course i thought man did you see how
they were they could run the ball at
will they should have ran the ball more
with andy reid last night i think i
think that's one area he missed out on
and they missed kareem hunt you know
those are two things i thought of as i
was watching the game going this is the
type of game they need sammy watkins and
kareem hunt or at least you know another
guy to play off of tyree kill when teams
are taking away those deep passes that
the chiefs like to throw
and that's exactly what anthony lynn the
coach of the chargers said after the
game the plan was to limit tyree kill's
explosive plays to win the fourth
quarter and win the turnover battle they
didn't win the turnover battle but they
they took away the explosive plays they
won the fourth quarter and it's almost
like the chiefs had it so easy early on
you know they're up 14 nothing and and
it they just kind of got a little
complacent like this is going to be easy
right and we've seen this movie before
where andy reid teams have leads that
they blow and whether it's in the
playoffs whether it's in the regular
season and you talked about them getting
away from the run i thought damien
williams more than past the eyeball test
he comes in he gets it done but but i
feel like the chiefs thought that that
that initial wave was going to continue
and 14 nothing was going to end up being
42 to 14 and it just didn't happen and
when it didn't happen they didn't know
what to do like they couldn't do what
they wanted to do and the charges took
away like you said the deep stuff and
they weren't able to go back to the the
dink and dunk of the alex smith days and
right and and before you know it you're
out of time that's it and i think that's
what makes the decision to go for two
even more brilliant by anthony lynn you
don't want to give patrick mahomes
another chance to go down the field and
do patrick mahomes things yes you want
to take that game right then in that
moment here's anthony explaining his
thought process after the game on going
for two and going for the win
you know we was gonna go for two the
whole time at the end of that game
because i believe in these guys
what was awesome can you just kind of
take us through the two point your
thought and just your certainty that
you're good we didn't come here we came
in to win and uh
so to me it was a no-brainer
you know i've talked to different
coaches throughout the course of the
year about this thought process going
forward on fourth down going for two and
there are so many factors that go into
it and it's so much more than analytics
it's what what do you feel about the
play that you would call and do you want
to project confidence in your guys even
if they didn't get that last night chris
the fact that anthony lynn was so
resolute the fact that he told ken
wisenhunt before they even got the ball
back from the chiefs if we get the ball
back and score we're going for two
that's the kind of thing that can
galvanize a team and carry a team and
and this was a team that was destined to
be in the playoffs either way but now
that they've gotten the win and now that
they're guaranteed to be in and now
they've got a shot at the one seat even
if they don't get it look i mean the the
the irony here would be the charges of
the last team in the afc that needs home
field advantage we've seen them go they
are 6-0 away from los angeles this year
yeah all their games are on the road
they've been down by 16 at the half in
pittsburgh they came back and won they
were down 14 with five minutes left last
night they came back in one this is a
team that is not going to be scared of
going into new england or back to kansas
city or anywhere they have to go if they
don't win the division so they win the
division and they get home field
advantage that's just gravy for them i i
kind of feel like they'd rather go on
the road than be at home maybe they
think they'll thrive more i think the
only benefit is you play one less
playoff game it's one less opportunity
to lose and get knocked out so
it's amazing where this chargers team
now is i hope la embraces them the way
they've embraced the rams and it could
be that both number one seats come from
los angeles this year yeah it certainly
could be uh they're an exciting football
team i know that they're a fearless
football team and you know back to your
point about galvanizing the locker room
and making everybody rally together like
yes there's they're definitely a valid
point because
even if they missed that two-point
conversion that would be the type of
thing where players would go okay okay i
could live with that i could live with
our coach going for the win right there
that was the right play that crappy
defense and secondary and we got all
these studs at wide receiver and phillip
rivers that was the right move so you're
even if that didn't work it wasn't going
to blow up in anthony lynn's face within
the locker room they were gonna be like
okay our coaches got confidence in us
and and we like that so hey the chargers
i i still look at them as of course a
dangerous team in the afc i think the
afc is up for grabs all together and
just think they didn't have melvin
gordon or an eckler out there last night
too to run the football and have that
kind of aspect of the game that they're
also very good at and we've seen that
throughout the year so they're a team
that's really didn't even put on their
best display last night i don't think
the chiefs did either i think they're
both dangerous but again this is another
team that showed somewhat of the formula
a little bit like the denver broncos and
the arizona cardinals played the chiefs
they did the kind of the same thing
let's drop everybody back we got a
pretty good front four let's keep
everything underneath and let's see if
andy reid can be patient and mahomes can
be patient and throw the ball underneath
and go on these long drives and like i
said
i really think the chiefs dropped the
ball by not running the ball a little
bit more that's the weakness to the
chargers i talked about it a little
yesterday how small they are if
anybody's out there pull up their roster
look at their defensive tackles they
only play one linebacker they play three
safeties most of the game they have
issues we saw the chiefs rip off some
runs there and i just feel like
sometimes the chiefs and andy reed can
get a little too uh thrilled with the
pass play
well that's right and and think about it
when you aren't doing the underneath
passes because you've got a guy that can
periodically or more consistently than
that throw the ball down the field with
authority you you it's and if you take
that away that's the thing what do you
do in the moment when someone is taking
away what you do best that's why bill
belichick does this all the time right
it rattles a coach it rattles a team
they've taken away what we want to do
yeah and now we have to do something we
really don't want to do are we ready to
do the thing we don't want to do and and
that short was it chris short week
preparation no doubt about it did andy
reid and the coaching staff in kansas
city have a chance to think this through
right and come up with all the
permutations if they take away tyree i
mean they were more worried about tyreek
hill being able to play not how are the
chargers going to defend him but what
did they devise in that three-day window
and how much better could they have been
right if it would have been a full week
to get ready for the game yeah that's i
i mean i'm glad you brought it up
because i didn't want to be to bring it
up because i do every week i feel like
but it was something that went through
my mind a number of times during the
game going you know hey if you gave andy
reid a few extra days and they were
going to play these deep zones i promise
you he would have found another handful
of plays to come up and go okay if they
do this i got a plan b for this and
we'll be able to shred it apart a little
bit either way it was it was all level
on both sides the chargers outplayed
them in the big moments and really made
the big plays and kudos to philip rivers
man it's a guy that's been through a lot
there the chargers and i'm really happy
he's like i feel like it's almost like
with him and drew brees it's like the
john elway feel at the end of his career
where you're like come on man let's win
one we can do this like i feel like i'm
part of their team both right now
rooting for both of them so it's kind of
cool
well and breeze has his from nine years
ago rivers is the one who does all the
other older quarterbacks i mean tom
brady ben roethlisberger drew brees
they've got theirs aaron rodgers has his
but philip rivers doesn't have his and
this may be the year that he gets it or
at least it's the last best chance he
may have to ever get one the way this
team's playing although i don't know
next year may be every bit as good of a
chance if they can continue to play the
way they've been playing all right
chargers great news they got the win
they could get the one seed chiefs where
do they pick up the pieces and go from
here they have a very difficult game
coming up in nine days and the seahawks
are going to be ready
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports